No. Not the American.
No, I'm begging you...
No! Don't!
No! Please! No! Don't!
No, don't!
Don't do this!
Let me go!
Don't leave me  in here.
Let me out.
I'm innocent.
I'm innocent!
I'm begging you, please!
Hi everyone its charlie I got a lot of
requests to do a stranger thing season 3
video so this will be for the ending in
the special post-credit scene normally
they do not do post-credit scenes for
stranger things so this is actually a
pretty big deal they won't to let you
know that there will be a season 4 and
they're all coming back but there were a
couple really big hanging plot threads
about what happened to a couple of the
main characters so we'll break it down
if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the
easter-egg videos we have a whole bunch
of stuff and Comic Con trailers coming
really soon The Witcher Netflix series
with Henry Cavill is going to drop its
first trailer in a couple weeks so of
course I'll be doing videos for that too
but careful for spoilers if you have not
seen all of strangers things season 3
because we'll be talking about the
ending so rampant spoilers here we go so
the very end in the Battle of the star
court Mall Billy who'd been controlled
by the mind flare all season possessed
in the exact same way that will was
possessed by it during season two become
sort of a proxy for the mind flare in
addition to that giant gross-looking
monster that was an amalgamation of
biomatter from all the rats and the
other people turns into a very Star Wars
Return of the Jedi ending fight Darth
Vader turning on the Emperor because of
course they're referencing a Star Wars
movie they reference every 80s movie and
TV shows that you've ever seen during
stranger things so they're Darth Vader
turns on their Emperor after 11 chosen
as happy memories of his childhood with
his mother they try to humanize Billy a
little bit more this season instead of
just making him the turbo douche that he
was during season two he sacrifices
himself to delay the mind flayer long
enough for hopper and Joyce down inside
the Russian facility to deactivate that
special energy being that the Russians
were using to open a new gate to the
upside down some of the references they
were making with the Maul the star Court
mall during season 3 were playing on
people's fears during the 1980s that
malls were destroying small towns they
turned it into a literal thing genre
style where the mall itself was this
evil creation of the Russians designed
to distract people so that they could
try to open a new gate to the upside
down in Hawkins because they were
unsuccessful trying to do it back in
Russia so the Russians this season we're
just trying to do the
same thing that the Hawkins facility was
trying to do in the first two seasons
open a door to the upside-down hopper
and Joyce are successful in destroying
the machine in malfunctions and once it
blows up the gate between dimensions
closes severing the link between the
mind flayer and all the things in our
dimension that it's controlling
including the gross giant monster which
basically deactivates and then Billy who
the monster had already killed so if all
the long-running characters Billy is
really probably one of the few actual
deaths that we can confirm one of the
first big questions that they raised
though is is that when hopper and Joyce
destroy the energy beam it's seemingly
malfunctions this giant energy discharge
vaporizes all the Russians in the room
but you do not see hopper die you don't
see him at all for that matter nobody
know nothing he just seemingly
disappears and Joyce who doesn't totally
understand what's going on just assumes
that he died in the explosion - so
that's what she tells everyone when she
comes back up top outside of the mall
but after everyone goes on summer
vacation coming back for season four
next year there's even a sign that they
drive past on their way out of town
saying come back to Hawkins soon just
reminding you that there will be a
season for all those characters will
come back there's a final shot of them
closing the door to wills house as they
leave and as the credits start it seems
like it's starting to snow across the
blackness of the screen just the credits
you hear this cold winter wind blowing
remember that because it's a visual
metaphor for what actually happened to
hopper at the end of the season then the
actual post credits scene starts with a
transition to come Chaka Russia which is
way over in the northeastern corner of
Russia way up here three months have
gone by since the end of the season and
we're in an underground Russian military
base two Russian guards walk past a row
of cells one goes to open a cell the
other guard says no not the American
remember that they proceed to the next
cell and pull a Russian prisoner out
who's screaming please don't take me
we've never met him before this is the
first time we've ever seen this
character they haul him down a flight of
stairs and throw him in a cage to feed
him to the demo dog that they had teased
earlier this season that Dustin
mentioned when Lucas's little sister was
asking about this huge cage
hey listen yeah how big did you say that
demogorgon was big 19 or so why but the
big surprise is is that the demo dog has
evolved into its final boss form another
brand-new white demogorgon the reason
it's white is just to let you know that
it's a new different one because eleven
destroyed the first demagogue and at the
end of season one which you know also
remember that too because the ending of
season three is very similar to what
happened at the end of season one but
that just means that the mind flayer
still has a toehold in our world through
this demogorgon whether or not the
Russians have a lot of control over the
demogorgon issues another thing linking
the mind flayer to our world so the mind
flayer is maybe defeated but not
absolutely destroyed the big hopper
twist of course is that he's still alive
of course he's that prisoner in that
underground Russian facility he's the
American that they mentioned but you ask
how did hopper get all the way to Russia
if his body wasn't found anywhere in the
wreckage immediately after the accident
in the basement of this facility of the
mall the best theories are that one
because the machine was creating a
doorway to the upside down hopper
somehow entered the upside down in that
big blast got trapped in there the same
way that eleven got sucked into the
upside down when she killed the first
demagogue and at the end of season one
and then she got trapped there for a
while maybe hopper got stuck in there at
some point in the days or weeks after
the Russians were able to extract him
from the upside down and then threw him
in this prison for questioning in
Kamchatka
Russia like I said it's unclear if the
Russians have control over this
brand-new demagogue again but second
theory is is that we know the demagogue
ins have the ability to freely travel
between dimensions it's clear that the
demagogue an escaped in the chaos of
this finale escaped its cage somehow and
then the Russians recaptured it later so
it's possible that in the chaos the
demagogue and grabbed hopper drugged him
into the upside down then out of it in
all the chaos and that's when the
Russians picked him up and threw him in
prison because the Russians have not
stopped their attempts to open wormholes
to the upside down that's still
something that they wanted to do but you
see how they're basically saying that
the same thing happened to hopper at the
end of season 3 that happened to 11 at
the end of season 1 that's why for a
brief second when you see this door
train
to the blackness of the credits you see
what it looks like spores of the upside
down falling across the screen a visual
metaphor telling you that hopper
traveled through a door into the upside
down but then somehow the Russians
picked him up and threw him in prison
they gave hopper the 11 moment from the
end of season 1 so of course they're
going to have to rescue him in season 4
whether or not that means road trip to
Russia or the Soviet Union because this
is still the 80s or if the Russians
bring him back to the United States
we'll see it would be cool for a change
of pace to see the kids actually go on a
road trip to the Soviet Union at the
height of the Cold War but I think it
just depends on how they want to wrap
things up and whether or not there's
going to be a season 5 after season 4 one
of the big teasers of season 3 that they
didn't completely pay off is that they
said that the only way to win for good
and stop the mind flare would be to
destroy the mind flayer itself instead
of just destroying its agents like the
demagogue and during season 1 all the
people that were mine flayed like Billy
or the giant gross monster at the end of
season 3 the mind flayer itself is still
alive and well
inside the upside-down so at some point
they'll either have to go to the upside
down and destroy the mind flayer there
with the help of the other Esper's that
11 met during season 2 or the reverse
happens the mind flayer fully physically
makes it into their dimension and they
defeated on their earth but just
remember that until they defeat the mind
flayer itself this won't be over it will
keep trying to make its way into our
dimension and take over that's kind of
what it does it's sort of like Dormammu
during the Doctor Strange movie it rules
over dimensions and it sort of collects
other dimensions and takes them over one
at a time so the mind flayer moves from
dimension to dimension until all things
are connected to the mind player they
also kind of did that with ego the
Living Planet during guardians of the
galaxy volume to grow and spread
covering all that exists until
everything
if you have any other big questions
about the season just post them in the
comments below and I'll try to answer
them but obviously there will be season
4 next year they haven't said a whole
lot about it I don't know if they're
going to comic-con but like I said
Netflix is going to have a really big panel
for The Witcher TV series where they'll
drop the first trailer that's going to
start later this year I believe in
December and I will be doing episode
videos for that while you wait for
everything click here for my spider-man
far from home post credit scene and
Easter egg videos and click here for
that brand-new Shazam Black Adam seat
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight!